because your [ __ ] is so tight and it's
just bit bit yeah
and there's and every scene has like
[ __ ] eight guys in it and it's just
like oh my god does it go straight from
the shot to the editing bay or how does
that work
um
let's get into the minutia of editing i
think this is what
so when you have a dirty over what what
program are they using is that a stutter
cut there
they record on avid or they ended on
avid they i do believe it goes straight
in there and and we take our time we'll
we'll shoot for like
a week or two and then we'll just shut
down and they'll work on it so by the
end of it
we can be more targeted about what we're
even going to shoot like and then how
does it work with all of those guys
people got to be like dude you didn't
get my
[ __ ] backflip in there why why isn't
that oh dude i landed on those attacks
for
nothing nary a personality in the film
has not had butt hurt moments where they
really really like third temper tantrum
well more like feelings tantrums well
what you guys do to your body the fact
that no one's gonna see it and it's like
so i did that for nothing so i can feel
that when i'm 80. yeah right
just lost a testicle for nothing yeah
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]